we're going to have to show you a clip
from MSNBC The televised mental
institution this is Joy Reed who is a
neo-racist I think she's probably unwell
mentally this is the same woman who
after that shooting in evaldi where that
kid shot 18 kids and I think three
teachers her show the next day she led
it by saying that he was not mentally
ill but this was only about guns I mean
this woman is is really really bananas
and I know I say bananas a lot but this
woman is a basket of rancid bananas here
she is talking about how the left is
winning the culture War now note the
Glee she's she expresses this with and
listen to all of the things that she
describes as wins and then you really
think about it if if this what she
describes is the America that you want
to live in the America that your parents
want to live in that your grandparents
maybe came here for and what say I don't
know maybe Dr Martin Luther King Jr was
all about
I hadn't watched in years but I actually
really enjoyed it although I'm not sure
everybody else did it was to put it
mildly a celebration of the very thing
the American right has turned into its
latest anti-wokness Boogeyman diversity
equity and inclusion
the show open with Puerto Rican singer
Bad Bunny singing 99 in Spanish then
host Trevor Noah walked and talked
through a room that was diversity equity
and inclusion in human form
the first country Americana artist to
perform Brandy Carlisle was introduced
by her wife and daughters we saw the
first trans artist when a Grammy Kim
Petras who has a hit song with Sam Smith
the British singer who came out in 2019
as non-binary black acting Superstar
Viola Davis became an egot winning a
Grammy to add to her Golden Globe Oscar
and Tony Awards lizzo performed with her
amazing choir of many sized singers
the culture wars are over and the left
one like total defeat I can only imagine
the heads exploding in red States I
imagine Ron DeSantis is somewhere
stalking through his Governor's Mansion
trying to figure out how to ban the
Airing of the Grammys in Florida and
take away cbs's tax exemptions no
educational value queer Theory black
music
it's a helpful reminder that despite the
almost hysterical War the right is
waging to take the culture back to the
John Wayne era they are not just losing
they literally cannot win
actually lady you literally cannot win
because of our founding documents you
are a racist what you care about most is
the color of a singer's skin you also
seem to care if they're fat that counts
as diversity you're obsessed with their
racial makeup and their ethnic
background and their sexuality and
whether they chop their genitals off and
you think that's winning it's funny
because you're on MSNBC which basically
nobody is watching anymore it has a
cultural relevance because you've got
NBC behind it so you have one of the
world's largest corporations behind it
but me on this little show that we do
here with my ragtab group of people we
have more people who watch this show on
a daily basis with no budget other than
the one that our subscribers afford US
and whatever we make on ads and we're we
are doing something that is way more
culturally relevant actually you're at
the end of the Rope Grammy viewership
actually on a technical note has been
sinking year over year every year year
since 2011. so you tell me how you're
winning Joy Reed tell me about that
[Music]